من حيث معنى ايهاب جبرين الباحث
المختص في الشان الاسرائيليه سيد ايهاب
عمليه صعبه الليله في تل ابيب بهذا يصفها
رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
لماذا برايك اعتبرها صعبه بهذا بهذا الشكل
علما انه كانت هناك يعني
عمليات ربما
اكثر
واقوى داخل تل ابيب وحصدت قتل اكثر من
الاسرائيليين
نعم مساء الخير بدايه بدون ان نشكل من
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ككل يتعامل مع
العمليات في داخل تل ابيب
بشكل معين اكبر وضخم اكبر من اي مكان
ومنطقه اخرى يعتبرها القلب النابض
لهذه الدوله وربما التي يوجد عليها اجماع
كمنطقه ما بين
المستوطنين وما بين
الليبراليين وما الى ذلك طيب هذه النقطه
يعني ربما اذا كان هنالك منطقه يوجد عليها
اجماع ويوجد عليها نوع من
الشعور بالوحده اتجاه اي كارثه تحل بها
فهي منطقه تل ابيب بدون ادنى شكل هذا هذا
بدايه هذه النقطه الاولى واظن ان هنا يعني
نتنياهو يحاول ان يستغل هذا الزخم ويضخم
منه اكثر واكثر ليحاول
جموع المتظاهرين ضده وهم بدون المشاكل
يعني اغلبهم ما يسمى بمن يعيش في داخل
فقاعه تل ابيب وجوشدان منطقه بوشدان
فبالتالي وفق هذه المعادله نتنياهو يحاول
ان يستغلها اليه بدون ادنى شك هذا يعني
وافق مع ما جاء به يعني من قبل الزميل
بانه ذكر بان لو ربما هذه الحكومه تكون
سعيده مثل هذه العمليه في قلب تل ابيب وفي
هذا التوقيت بالذات يمكن ان يكسبها بعض
الوقت من التهدئه مع كل ما يجري من
مظاهرات وهذا ما يحاول ان يستغله نتنياهو
باعلانه عن حجم هذه العمليه لم يعلم ان
جيدا ان يعني
التعاطف
للمتظاهرين وتعاطف المعارضه مغاير عن يعني
عن تعاطفهم بالعمليات التي سبقت في القدس
وجمعات ذئب وما الى ذلك هذا بدايه هذه
النقطه الاولى التي يجب الاشاره اليها
ولكن بالرغم من كل ذلك يجب ان نتدارك
ونعلم جيدا ان
الكلاسيكيه المرحله التي كانت فيها عمليات
في هذه او كاخرى يعني تعطي بعض من الزخم
في الوحده في داخل الشعور شعور الوحده في
داخل الشارع الاسرائيلي ظن ان يعني
اسرائيل قد قطعت هذه المرحله ولا تظن ان
يعني هي بحاجه لصدمه كبيره اكبر من
عمليات قطير واحد هنا او هناك التي لكي
يعني تحاول ان توحده
[موسيقى]
السابقه اظن ان الشخص الذي وصلت اليه
اسرائيل في هذه المرحله تعدى هذه المرحله